successful marketing once meant
big-budget TV ad great print campaign in
radio jingles that stuck in your head
not anymore today 22% a video
consumption happens online 57% of text
consumption happens online and 67% of
music consumption happens online in a
world where life has gone digital
digital marketing is no longer an
alternate channel of its own that
businesses can choose to ignore it's
simply how marketing must be done and
there are tons of high-quality
high-paying jobs out there for the right
candidate and indeed.com reports 250,000
jobs in the US the Times of India
estimates are 150,000 jobs available in
India I've been a writer a speaker and a
working professional in digital
marketing for well over a decade I've
also been educating and training digital
markers for many years all around the
world and there are two questions I've
been asked over and over again what does
it take to be a successful digital
marketer what's the best way to get
there well there's tons of people
claiming they know digital marketing
engineers who are great at turning up
analytics dumps my friend Abhinav specs
are called data pure SEO s who promise
wild claim to page 1 rankings social
media gurus who will fail you like PPC
experts will be happy to help you spend
too much money at paid advertising what
the reality is knowing how to send a
tweet does that make good for a marker
posting family photos on Facebook does
it make you a facebook marketing
strategy and having a LinkedIn profile
is a long way from being a true LinkedIn
marketing guru for anyone getting into
the field whether you're an executive
can use understand the basic or a
marketing strategy who needs to guide a
team of professionals or even a
specialist who claims to be really an
expert and one or two core skill sets
need a sound understanding of all the
digital marketing skills and how they
work together
icon is 360 degrees foundation and all
the critical disciplines of digital
marketing is required for any
one who wants to understand and
contribute meaningfully to digital
marketing emissions we should be
comfortable with how all these
specialties build on one another how
they generate traffic optimizing for
visitor conversion developing valuable
content that your audience will share
and magnify nurturing leads with email
campaigns and paid search using social
media to protect your online reputation
while developing brand trust and
authority and measuring and testing
results to constantly improve your
campaigns what if you're aiming to be a
digital marketing specialist someone
whose job will be to strategize build
implement and measure digital marketing
initiatives that's you you need more
in-depth knowledge to be that kind of
specialist it's critical to cross right
in to three or four disciplines do what
the industry calls a t-shaped marker
someone who has a broad working
knowledge of all the skill sets and then
a deep knowledge of one or a few
specialties those markers that deep
specialized understanding in their areas
of expertise will lend the best roles
can earn up to 90% more than their
generals colleagues of large
organizations feel that their digital
marketing team is weak in one or more
areas a digital marketing yet only 46%
of companies are going to invest in
developing the digital skills of their
teams instead companies are looking for
experts who already have a developed
understanding of digital market how can
you be the expert they're looking for
well for entry-level digital marketing
roles or for entry-level digital
marketing roles digital marketing
managers or even those whose business
rules that aren't required digital
marketing heavy lifting our DMCA course
should provide everything you need a
high quality training plan a couple of
hands-on projects that will get you
industry ready in just six weeks with
the NCAA certification on your belt to
have that broad cross discipline
foundation we talked about to be able to
communicate with all the stakeholders
set realistic expectations with
achievable goals and be part of a
holistic team that work together
efficiently to maximize the impact of
your marketing and grow your business
the other hand if your goal is to that
t-shaped digital marketing specialist
there's going to lead teams to
strategize and manage digital marketing
initiatives we need more focused and
specialized training but for you and
recommend following your dmca training
with more advanced studies and web
analytics PPC SEO and social media
marketing
imagine having access to a structure
multi-step training program designed by
industry experts to provide you the
skills you need to excel at the job
training that teaches you not just the
foundation but gives you that deep dive
into mastering the strategies and
tactics other chosen discipline and
empowers you to innovate and create the
effective digital campaigns your company
deserves imagine getting live expert
mentoring and project work that can give
you the hands-on experience the industry
demands does that sound like the
training you need that's what I have
worked with simply learn to create it's
our digital marketing specialist masters
program the most effective way to be a
complete digital marketer